when I worked this place called Dakota
wine and feed I would save up they had a
rich Place dude when I was in high
school I went to live with this family
and had a re at the edge of the
neighborhood they had a fancy little s
uh sandwich and liquor shop called
Dakota's wine and feed
and they had dude they had all type of
cheeses in there they had Grover
they had damn
um Saint Sierra you know they had that
booyah base they had all kind of [__]
[__] French [__]
I mean let's be honest stuff that's
fancy is French
that bull your base brung that Brie
great there before that if I ever even
heard one of these words it was usually
like kind of a middle name of like a
black friend of mine you know oh that's
[__] Jerry Grover Jackson right there
you know
oh that's shantisha Bree Crandall you
know so these before that that's all it
was but now I'm hearing they had these
different types of meats man procy Auto
[__] lamb
I didn't even know people was trying to
eat lambs dude where I'm from you would
never eat a lamb if you saw a lamb you'd
pet it or look at it while you're trying
to go to sleep
and then you get over into these fancier
areas and these [__] are eaten Lambs
dude
first of all lamb uh number one animal
in the Bible how about that maybe don't
eat it
maybe don't eat lamb just for the soul
thought that you know they say the Lamb
of God
maybe God's trying to drop you a h-i-n-t
on what not to
h-u-n-t you feel me
don't kill Lambs
and then you go to these fancy
neighborhoods and they eat nut you know
they got them lamb scallions and [__]
you see some rich dude he's driving a
Corvette and he's just throwing chunks
of lamb in the air and his little son
little Fauntleroy the fifth he's
catching him in his jaw and they out
here eating the eating the damn just
[__] just nibble snacking on the Lord
doing 45 miles an hour in a school zone
and probably wearing shoes made out of
damn chalk a lot
and that's who they are boy rich people
so anyway I would work in there and I
would save these pieces of um I would
save up all the nice stuff off of those
the things that rich people didn't need
I would save it on one plate
and at the end of the night I would make
me a big ass sandwich bro
one huge Rich hitter dude and I pick up
that big huge
sandwich bruh and just take a bite of
that thing and say one day I'm gonna
have me something
nice
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one our next one